gavel is not just any primate he's a
clan chief and by now good friends with
innocently tackle the zoologist has
rescued over 600 drill monkeys and
brought them to this center in southern
Nigeria many of them were previously
held captive aspects others as orphans
whose parents were hunted for bush meat
he tackled is determined to stop them
from dying out what I love physically
among this animal is that they are
unique and they are found only here if
we don't work passionately with these
animals then they will go extent and the
possibility of these animals to go
extend I think I'll prefer to die than
seeing this animals going extend the
habitat of the drills is shrinking
they are omniverse they'll eat anything
including fruits like papaya
for example keeping them in food is hard
work and costly the Panda realist
foundation that runs the drill ranch has
the purchase tons of vegetables and
fruits per week we lack funding yet
seriously and the animals are eating we
have more than 600 animals if everyone
is eating say hundred naira a did that's
about 60 thousand era it did and where
is this phones coming from
60,000 naira that's almost 190 euros
rescue center staffed by the foot in a
nearby village in part to help boost
villagers income that way there's less
likelihood that they'll resort to
illegally hunting the animals in the
world for their meat the drill ranch
couldn't survive without outside help
volunteers come here from all over the
world there's a breeding conservation
program component there's a component in
working to educate the nearby
communities and you see that in every
interaction with the staff with the
buying animal feeds from the village
from having school children come and
visit the project every single facet of
what happens here is conservation action
and that feels very rewarding new
primates can only be integrated in the
drill enclosures once they have been
tested for disease here in the
veterinary station the ranch manager
trains volunteers how to use trunked
Eliza darts in case they have to rescue
a drill in the wild now it's time for
him to brief his staff and volunteers
most of the local staff we used the
Hunt's drills themselves now they carry
out anti-poaching patrols innocent
attacker dreams of being able to release
the animals into the world someday soon
the program is very successful the
animals are healthy they are very strong
and they are ready to go so once we have
support then we are ready to take the
animals straight to where they belong
they don't belong here they belong to
the wild and that is their home but
chief Gavin and his clan wouldn't really
be safe there are only three thousand
rooms left in the world and they are
still being hunted so for the moment at
least they seem better off on the drill
ranch under the watchful eye of innocent
attacker